[Musique]
que signifie pour vous bien manger est
ce que tu sais pas combien par
d'épicerie non vraiment possible
nous notre famille pour mes quatre
enfants donc ça coûte cher des épiceries
mais
6 par année j'en ai vraiment aucune
aujourd'hui des élèves du 2e secondaire
de l'école sophie barat du quartier
ahuntsic à montréal seront pas
l'épicerie hockey le professeur de
mathématiques guillaume caisse ou est
l'instigateur d'un projet scolaire fait
conjointement avec les professeurs de
français et d'éducation physique
le volet vitré s'est inscrit dans un
projet qui s'appelle mon avenir ils
doivent donc se trouver un emploi avoir
un salaire et où il effectivement
l'épicerie fait partie du projet parce
que c'est un peu une portion importante
d'un budget
quand on sera plus vieux bon en fait
ce projet tente de faire des élèves des
consommateurs avertis en les aidant à
décrypter les bons produits pour faire
les choix adéquat
ont ils ont dû établir des menus de type
pour un déjeuner energy souhaite une
conférence qu'ils ont eu de la part
d'une nutritionniste viandes volailles
poissons et le tofu silva qui concerne
le tofu dans la classe
ah ouais c'est bon ça bravo qu'avec ce
projet là bas ça me permet de voir qui
effectivement des mathématiques que ce
soit au niveau du calcul de la masse des
volumes évidemment des coûts baissent à
une utilité donc en secondaire dans plus
y voit les proportions et alors ça
permet d'appliquer concrètement ce
qu'ils ont vu en classe à l'épicerie les
élèves ont tenté d'appliquer les
conseils de la conférencière en
nutrition avant de se rendre à
l'épicerie trois ingrédients ont fait
que ça débute bien on les a déjà comparé
mais en plus cette sorte là ces vidéos
alors moi j'ai tendance à prendre
bien parce que moi je mange qui toi
comme ingram de secret
le succès du single 0 grâce matin qu'est
ce que tu as appris que tu ne savais pas
j'ai aussi appris que par exemple que
les ingrédients et l'oncle c'est mauvais
de marrakech choisir des bijoux à
respecter de conservation des données
personnelles
c'est tout un skull le rôle de la
professeur de français mme leite lilas
vigueur est tout aussi capital que mon
rôle c'est de faire en sorte que y lis
bien les étiquettes en les ingrédients
la valeur nutritive est ce que les
promesses qu'on voit sur les emballages
sont au rendez vous c'est de travailler
beaucoup l'analyse comparative parce que
quand on fait notre épicerie tout est à
propos de ça comment tu veux savoir sur
pour les intolérances au la comec quand
on a des intolérances des allergies on
est obligé d'analyser chaque produit
pour voir ça nous convient ou non
qu'est-ce que vous calculez on calcule
les proportions pour le yogourt pour
savoir combien
ben combien sa volonté pour un match
qu'est-ce que vous preniez en compte
mais en fait c'est très simple si le
prix selon le nombre de grandes qu on a
décidé qu'on va manger pour une portion
est donc on va diviser en fonction parce
que le c200 fin une grande chance pour 4
on a des bons échos de la part des
parents qui sont à ses contacts
car laurent femme mettant les
accompagner l'épicerie et des points
un esprit critique face à leurs choix
alimentaires
champignon mortel et zellige bouge dans
les dix à exactement parce qu'il me
nombreuses et les kg c'est donc une fois
qu'ils ont terminé leur épicerie qu'ils
ont chiffré tout ça évidemment ils
retournent en classe et là ils doivent
calculer exactement combien chaque
ingrédient chaque item leur côté sont
surpris de voir la partie importante que
l'épicerie représente dans un budget
heures moi je me suis retrouvé un
appartement alors j'ai 17 ans et je
savais rien de la vie je savais pas
comment faire une épicerie je savais
même pas ce qu'est ce que c'était de
manger équilibré et puis l'aubade est
d'offrir à ses élèves le la chance
d'avoir un regard concret sur ce que
sait faire l'épicerie de voir que bon ça
ça coûte cher d'avoir peut-être un petit
peu plus de respect pour le travail des
parents mais moi je me dis que pour
l'instant j'en profite parce que c'est
moi qui paye donc
mais j'y pense pas rapide à jour ou
l'autre ça va venir puis
voilà je préfère poli pensée pour l'est
[Musique]